hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 3rd 2020 what's going on
oh man you know the day after the Super
Bowl is always such a bummer unless
you're a team one for the rest of us
it's just like ah mad football season
now what do I do
you know what you do you watch [ __ ]
hockey or basketball you pick one of the
other college or pro whatever you're
[ __ ] d-list
anyways congratulations to your Kansas
City Chiefs the 2018 Superbowl champions
their second championship they won Super
Bowl four in Super Bowl 50 for that has
to be a record fact I know it is as far
as like wins between super bowls I mean
the the Jets will break it someday
whatever the [ __ ] they win it but as for
right now that is your that is your
record so congratulations you got to be
going crazy folks you got to be going
crazy and in in in [ __ ] Kansas City
Missouri or if you're the president he
thinks Kansas City Kansas you know it's
not those things that makes me just not
like Trump it's when he just openly
defends bigots and racists it's just
[ __ ] like the fact that people can
still [ __ ] sit there and be like is
just beyond me and I don't mind
conservative thought it's just you know
how about you let everybody sit down at
the [ __ ] table man anyway
condolences to the 49ers who were right
there with 10 minutes left winning 20 to
10 that close to winning their 6th and
joining the Pittsburgh Steelers
and your New England Patriots as the
though I don't know biggest winners of
Super Bowls but for some reason the
[ __ ] league is a hundred years old
and you only need six titles to be the
[ __ ] Yankees which makes no [ __ ]
sense they just you know they just blew
off their first 50 years don't
understand it
we'll never understand it will never I
that that type of [ __ ] I don't
understand politicians in LA with this
stupid petition asking the Red Sox to
give back the World Series title from
last year while it's like okay
well let if you're really about Fair
Play then you should you should also
give back the Los Angeles Lakers 2002
NBA title considering there was a
mobbed-up ref that fixed the series
against the Sacramento Kings so what is
it LA do you really give a [ __ ] or do
you just give a [ __ ] about yourselves
speaking of which I had so much fun
watching that game because I didn't have
a dog in the fight and I thought it was
so cool seeing the Chiefs in there and
the way they did the end zone like the
way it was way back in the day it's
exact same end zone I feel like the same
color you know 64 Tosh powered crap that
[ __ ] was great to see the the 49ers back
in it I don't know they look cool played
each other I don't know I really enjoyed
it and then I was just at this party
watching 49er fans one in particular
absolutely losing his mind
at the [ __ ] officiating in that game
and I got to tell you I'm impartial here
he wasn't wrong I thought one of the
major advantages the 49ers had was their
front four and I got to be honest with
the level of [ __ ] holding that they
just didn't call I mean we were seeing
it in live time I would just be going
holding they grabbed that Bossa guy they
just right underneath his pads and just
hang on
unlike major [ __ ] plays it was such a
you know just such a weird thing like
you know when I call it holding
like they barely called it the whole
[ __ ] game and then something they
never call offensive pass interference
all of a sudden they call it which I
understand why they called it but I can
also understand why you wouldn't call it
that was kind of a tough call it's just
one of those games every time there's a
game like somebody's you know it's just
somebody's day and you're not going to
get the call so 49ers was not their day
but despite that they were still up 20
to 10 and they couldn't close them out
and the whole game went exactly the way
I thought it was going to go until that
final final 10 minutes and I think the
big moment was when they started
blitzing and the 49ers had no answer for
it the receivers needed to pick it up
they needed to break off their routes
they needed Kaepernick they needed to
give him something to throw it which I
saw [ __ ] Brady have to deal with all
year and and it's so [ __ ] hilarious
they always blame the guy with the ball
and you know if there's like [ __ ] you
know eight guys up on the line of
scrimmage
you know you have to break off your
route I would think you know continue to
run the [ __ ] thing with you back to
your quarterback I think that that was
the that was the big the big change in
the game and what was so weird was they
were they were shutting down
what's-his-face the whole [ __ ] game
Tyreke Hill was just a complete
non-factor and then all of a sudden in
the fourth quarter the guy you know he's
gonna throw him now and then all of a
sudden they couldn't stop from the whole
game yeah it was just so yeah it was
kind of it was just weird it was just
the Kansas City Chiefs like three
playoff games in a row we're beat and
then just decided they were gonna win
the game and nobody could do anything
about it so as much as the officiating
was [ __ ] you know it's always gonna be
I guess one side of the or maybe you
notice more if your team loses but it
was just their day
and any question will [ __ ] it
officiating that you had I mean you
still were up ten points with ten
minutes left and it's you can't [ __ ]
and then you'll lose by like ten you'll
end up like [ __ ] tour 2011 you let up
like [ __ ] 21 points but I I you know
I don't know it's a it's a new day man I
watched a better defense like I was
watching that Super Bowl and when it was
twenty to ten I was like I've seen this
game a thousand times this is the
[ __ ] the Giants beat in the Broncos
in 86 this is the Giants beat in the
[ __ ] you're gonna hear Giants a lot
in this okay because Bill Belichick is
the defensive coordinator on all these
teams by the way I mean maybe he wasn't
in 86 but I pretty sure he was at 90
Giants first the bills the Patriots
first the [ __ ] and you know greatest
show on turf the Giants versus the
undefeated Patriots you just see it time
and time again where this [ __ ]
offense comes the [ __ ] Saints first
the Colts in 2010 oh my god these guys
this car in a zillion [ __ ] points you
know I think the [ __ ] you know
high-powered offense is going to be 42
to [ __ ] in 17 or whatever then they come
in and then the [ __ ] the best defense
in the league just shuts him down
Redskins Raiders with [ __ ] Leste's
Mike Haynes and all of them so the whole
thing was going that way and I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened in the last
ten minutes there was a number of plays
where they had an opportunity to sack
mahomes and I thought they went for the
ball it just simply didn't tackle the
guy it was weird
and he had a horrible day until the last
ten minutes and the final score is all
that matters so congratulations to the
Chiefs and it's a new era it's a new era
my old theory does not I think does not
work anymore we're a better defense can
be
a better offense Chiefs proved me wrong
and lost 200 bucks to Keith Robinson but
I will tell you man
they must be going [ __ ] nuts in
Kansas City that is a [ __ ] great
thing and I was so happy for [ __ ]
Andy Reed to finally get one
all of these [ __ ] [ __ ] who don't
know [ __ ] about football myself included
but I never trashed any Reed you know
giving them she's never won the big one
you don't want the big one it's just
like it you know so much of it also goes
to like you know who you [ __ ] GM is
who your ownership is I mean when you
start coaching a [ __ ] team that just
never won one ever where he wasn't
Philadelphia let me put it this way all
you have to know about coaching at one
point the Cleveland Browns had Bill
Belichick in Nick Saban at the same time
and they fired them so go figure that
one out but I had a great time at the
the Super Bowl party I was at when I was
at this guy had some amazing amazing
amazing amazing cigars
and I did not smoke one I kept thinking
like well maybe I'll be that guy at big
events I'll smoke a cigar and I was just
thinking you know what I know what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna smoke that
thing and then I'm gonna have to reset
the clock as far as how many days I've
gone without smoking and then it's not
gonna be a big deal in a couple days if
I smoke another one so I'm going to a
big sporting event in April and I think
maybe I'll have one then I don't know
maybe I will or my birthday in June I
came awfully awfully close I was looking
in the humidor that was the loo oh he
doesn't have oh yes he does have the ah
but uh
you know I got the green light from my
wife because she thinks I'm nuts
with this [ __ ] she goes you know I mean
just have a glass of wine because she
can do that I can't I keep trying to
explain that to her cuz there's a lot of
you guys [ __ ] with these theories
like uh dude your wife's making you stop
it's me I'm doing it so she's always
going like have a [ __ ] drink Jesus
Christ you [ __ ] wound up just don't
have 90 but I keep going to or like I
don't know how to do that she's like
alright well go [ __ ] play your drums
then go run around the block something
so anyway uh yeah I was just kind of
like with the cigars I mean when I first
started smoking like I had one a year
I'd be at the Rose Bowl I'd sit on the
golf cart golf course and I would just
smoke a [ __ ] cigar and uh and it was
great and then I just I just didn't for
the rest of the year and I told you that
I was at one time when I was on a movie
and I bought a box of cigars for people
and we went on this booze cruise on this
little [ __ ] boat we were shooting
something in Boston and the boat was
just too small there was too many people
who didn't smoke and it would just be
[ __ ] obnoxious if I started smoking
you know so so so I didn't and uh I kept
the box and then I [ __ ] and went home
yeah so I brought the thing home the box
home or whatever and trying to remember
this [ __ ] here yeah and then I just
start I just I didn't want to throw him
out and I just [ __ ] smoked him over
the course of like [ __ ] I don't know
a month and then that was it so anyway
I'm trying to I'm doing this [ __ ] cuz
I'm a [ __ ] old dad and I'm doing the
math going like you know I got to be
around here so anyway congratulations to
me and the Kansas City Chiefs
anyway plowing ahead here guys
stop asking me [ __ ] questions about
that Kobe helicopter crash I have 230
hours people just keep [ __ ] sending
me emails about it and stuff and like
there's gonna be a report it'll come out
in a year to 18 months probably 18
months because of the level of intention
to this thing it'll tell you everything
they'll [ __ ] nihlus reassemble the
helicopter as much as they'll figure
they they will figure out what the [ __ ]
happened
it is so [ __ ] ridiculous listening to
all of these [ __ ] people who don't
even have a [ __ ] pilot's licence
saying a special VFR and ifr and we view
the ended in the soup and Scud running
it's like I can barely explain half of
that [ __ ] I'm studying it right now and
listen these [ __ ] idiots who don't
even fly okay you know it dick I think
Kobe told them to [ __ ] no is that what
you think what is that based on cuz you
don't like the Lakers like hey it's just
[ __ ] ridiculous just but I guess
that's what people do I mean all right
I'm talking about the [ __ ] Superbowl
going you know they really weren't Colin
Holden the [ __ ] do I know
anyway plowing ahead
so congratulations there to the Kansas
City Chiefs and Erie finally get the
monkey off his back all of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] I went on Twitter to check out
you know all the [ __ ] that people would
say and I saw these people going after
[ __ ] Richard Sherman you're such
[ __ ] [ __ ] only these [ __ ]
Buffalo Wild Wing man titted [ __ ]
[ __ ] whose balls would [ __ ] crawl
up in them if they were playing a
preseason game in the NFL [ __ ]
picking on this guy who came back from
one of the worst injuries you can have
as far as like you know your speed you
know when Achilles injury he's come back
he's still playing shut down football on
the corner he gets beat on a couple and
all of these [ __ ] [ __ ] are giving
him [ __ ] I don't know I just think
that's really who actually tweets at the
player you know what I mean like what
the
[ __ ] happened to you and your childhood
that you do that it's unbelievable but
then look at me I looked it up just to
see what what the level of [ __ ] that
people were being I actually Ted I
actually you know what I did before I
talked about the officiating is I just
looked it up to see if there was a lot
of talk about it and that kind of wasn't
only amongst like 49er fans so that's
why I was kind of like you know I don't
know what the [ __ ] do I know I just did
find that [ __ ] weird I don't know
so plowing ahead here let's see here
what else did I want to talk about oh so
I've been playing a lot of drums now
that I don't have any vices left I mean
I do oh by the way some [ __ ] [ __ ]
sent me an email about that that
documentary game-changers and he's goes
now you got to watch the the [ __ ] Joe
Rogan podcast cuz he had those guys on
and then the guy kind of clarifies what
he meant and it's just like this should
be a [ __ ] law against first of all
poisoning food which I don't know in
this whole [ __ ] war against terror
why you can give [ __ ] to cows that
people then give to their kids that
there's so many [ __ ] hormones that
that little girls are getting their
periods at ten years of age little girls
are getting their periods ten eleven
[ __ ] years old because of the amount
of hormones that these [ __ ] companies
have put into [ __ ] cows that ends up
in the milk that children are drinking
okay and they get less [ __ ] for that
than a [ __ ] stand-up comedian who
sends out a [ __ ] tweet meanwhile they
said they're telling me that they're
fighting [ __ ] terrorism we're for the
last 30 years I have to drink bottled
water because of all this [ __ ]
corporations they basically poisoned our
own [ __ ] water supply isn't what
doesn't wouldn't Isis love to do both of
those things [ __ ] with their food supply
and our water supply why aren't those
people could
terrorists why is it like putting
[ __ ] opioids or opiates whatever the
[ __ ] you call them Oh like
pharmaceutical companies the amount of
deaths that they caused not a [ __ ]
problem
Caitlyn Jenner joke raked over the
[ __ ] coals figure that one out it's
all about that [ __ ] money that's what
it's about right so if you're gonna go
conspiracy theory there that's why I
feel like you know sports leagues are
finessed now a lot of them I they just
think they're finessed in their effort
to go global and serve the stars like I
was joking during the game when I saw
mahomes bitching about a call he was at
a respectful distance but he was sort of
closing the distance to the referee
huddle and I was joking with the but
buddy of mine
I said hey as a Patriots fan as he wins
more and more rings the distance is
going to close between him and the
officials until he's right in the huddle
like I saw Tom Brady doing you just
start getting the [ __ ] calls because
everybody is making so much [ __ ]
money off of you so you watch is the
great Patrick mahomes builds his Hall of
Fame career
alright when he gets his second ring you
know God willing for all those
long-suffering chief ends you I say he
closes the distance between himself and
the referee huddle by 50% after his
second ring and if you get your third
ring which is an automatic you're in the
[ __ ] Hall of Fame
no questions acts you'll get in with two
but three forget about it you're you're
automatically a two you should be
probably I think you'll get it unless
you're Eli Manning who for some reason
the New York media just never respected
ever I don't understand it the entire to
his entire career they were calling for
his [ __ ] head I'll never understand
that you watch he's going to start
closing the [ __ ] distance
it's alright let's talk about some wolf
let's talk about some fun [ __ ] shall we
old freckles here old freckles
McGillicuddy is gonna be doing four
shows yes four shows in two nights in
the absolutely beautiful gorgeous City
of Vancouver Canada Vancouver British
Columbia one of the provinces there in
Canada I'm really looking forward to
that and sold freckles you know now that
I'm done playing [ __ ] TJ Hooker I
have to [ __ ] go I gotta go do a bunch
of spots which I am going to do and make
sure I got this hour up and running also
because I mean what is it Santa Ynez is
that how you say it I'm at the casino
this weekend on the 7th and I can't I'm
just very excited to be back into living
my life in real time which is one of the
greatest things ever about it being a
stand-up comedian and doing a podcast is
all of it exists in real time
like I don't edit this thing unless I
say something that I think some [ __ ]
white college chick you know who has no
sense of humor about herself and stop
trimming her pubes is listening then I'm
like alright I need to [ __ ] take that
out because I know and I don't need the
headache I don't need the fog every once
in a while take something out but for
the most part I don't all right I've
maintained this for a long-ass [ __ ]
time like the people in the writers room
the directors the [ __ ] crew who else
am i leaving out how hard that they
[ __ ] wore the editors how hard they
[ __ ] work is just it's next level
every time I've been on like a set and
stuff I'm like these people like that
they're they're the three defying
workaholics and so dedicated to making
sure if it's not exactly how they want
it they will stay there
all [ __ ] night it's unbelievable
because I know if I was in the directed
sham yeah [ __ ] it let's go [ __ ] out of
here miss the game
my priorities would be all [ __ ] up
speaking of which I missed that game
Bartnik was telling me from the puck off
podcast that there was like three fights
so I I signed up for the NA nhl.com
website so I can go back and watch that
game which I might today I know we ended
up winning that game de brusque got a
late one and then I caught a little bit
of the Minnesota game we went forward
enough and so we're we're cruising right
along here we're playing a little
tougher which I like you know so we
won't get bullied out of a Stanley Cup
victory like we did last year by the
slightly above-average st. Louis Blues
I'll never give it up for that team I'm
usually good about it - I usually
[ __ ] give it up but Jesus I'm not bad
at the Blues hey you know what that was
your game and they [ __ ] let you play
it for whatever reason I should get mad
at the officiating I guess but that
never sounds right
right if he's like I know you just
[ __ ] whining about it but uh
anyway yeah so I got four shows coming
up in Vancouver so I'm gonna try to
knock out a couple of special pop-up
shows where I run my hour here in Los
Angeles I'll try to keep you posted as
to when that's going to happen I might
have some some prizes for people who
show up
ie [ __ ] that I have around my house
gifts that I've gotten that I have no
room for that somebody else might be
into because you're a younger person and
you are at the beginning of your journey
of accumulating [ __ ] and as a special
bonus to people listen to my podcast
because there'll be a lot of people that
night there that night on whatever night
I do the show who don't listen to my
podcast yes here's some sage advice for
you about buying [ __ ] don't when you're
younger be
cuz it's just [ __ ] you have to pack up
when you when you want to move and if I
could if I could just go back in my life
to young Billy burr when I first moved
to New York City when I had a box of
clothes and I don't know what else if I
could just go back to that [ __ ] dude
then every time I bought a shirt
I took a shirt out of my closet and just
walked up to a [ __ ] homeless person
roughly my size and gave it to him if I
didn't keep all of this [ __ ]
memorabilia that I now have like this
emotional attachment to that you know
what is the worst is like you can I'm
gonna die someday and then some poor
[ __ ] family members that I have are
gonna have to like you know sift through
all of my [ __ ] I don't know I am I am a
that I would say don't accumulate [ __ ]
and go easy with the partying you know
you want it you want to stretch it out
well you can just be that person that
you know can smoke a stick or have a
glass of wine you know every once in a
while when the moment calls for that's
really a [ __ ] skill to have to be
like yeah this this is such a great meal
I would like a great you know hope let's
let's share a bottle of wine with this
incredible meal I wish I had done that
as opposed to just like you know just
having my foot to the floor and not
checking the oil and then you use up you
basically you have a finite number of
fun days is what I'm trying to tell you
as a young person and if you use them
all up you're gonna end up like me at a
Super Bowl where you're looking at some
of the finest [ __ ] cigars man has
ever made and you cannot partake
because you [ __ ] smoked like 20 a
month for [ __ ] you know four months
in a row you just can't [ __ ] I just
cannot stress like I really admired that
about my wife she can just [ __ ] do
something and then just stop I mean I
can stop too but I know if I start doing
it again it's gonna [ __ ] go off the
rails it's just gonna I don't know so if
I could if I could just go back again
and read and redo that I would not have
bought so much of the [ __ ] like now what
it is I have a conscious thing now that
when I go to a major sporting event like
I went to the the NCAA college football
Super Bowl this year and the only thing
I just my ticket stub is my is my
souvenir and unfortunate one and when I
walked in club soda Kenny gave it to me
via his phone he like air dropped it to
me and then I was like man and I didn't
even print it out because I'm not just
gonna have a ticket on a [ __ ] piece
of Xerox paper so I actually have no
souvenir of that other than like a
picture on my camera and I'm like the
you know that's kind of that's the way
to do it so I'm kind of I'm trying to
get away from that you know but I also
have you know a lovely lady in my life
and you know how they are with the
[ __ ] Amazon oh jesus oh Jesus with
the [ __ ] Amazon like every [ __ ]
week just more and more boxes are
showing up and it's just like and like
we get into it I'm like what is this
like I you know I just saw this thing I
like just like you know get off my case
man they get like all upset yeah and
it's just like we just as three people
in this lovely house that we finally
finished redoing and you
no that's another thing too when you
have enough [ __ ] bedrooms for people
and everybody you know has their own
[ __ ] bedroom and everybody's [ __ ]
chill and all that [ __ ] and one of you
says you know what we need we need more
space we need to move it's like no you
need a [ __ ] yard sale that [ __ ]
disease of consumption where you just
keep buying more and more and more and
more [ __ ] each I think back in the day
you know when I was a younger fella and
Nia first moved in with me we were
living together in a New York City
one-bedroom apartment and it was fine
you know it wasn't the biggest thing but
you know it was hilarious like we would
get into fights and there was nowhere to
go you kind of had to work it out you go
into the bedroom and close the door
I'll tell you what's tough on a [ __ ]
relationship a studio apartment you know
because you got to have that [ __ ]
thing where you just I have to go into
another [ __ ] walled-in space where
you can't see me and just [ __ ] chill
out and that just does not exist you
know in New York you know I mean you can
go for a [ __ ] walk but you know if
it's too cold or too humid out I don't
know then you go to like an
air-conditioned bar or a heated bar you
just start [ __ ] drinking yeah but I
will tell you that if I if I can go you
know I I definitely drew a line in the
sand where my garage like you can you
can still put a vehicle in there and I
really fight that thing when like [ __ ]
starts piling up and my wife starts
suggesting that we put it in the garage
I just say no we're not putting it in
the garage we're getting rid of it or
we're getting rid of something else and
whatever that something else is this
thing here that you want to put in the
garage is going to go there because we
are not going to have
a bunch of [ __ ] and as I look around
this [ __ ] room you know when I see I
see a bunch of [ __ ]
I see a bunch of [ __ ] we don't even need
so I saw Jeff Garlin do this a long time
ago he would go to his stand-up shows
and he would just he would give [ __ ]
away to people and it was always funny
but like somebody would it was it was
all so perfect because people would be
psyched
both ends was psyched he was psyched
because he was getting rid of it and
then the person was psyched because it
was something that they wanted and
obviously could use so you know I think
one of the greatest things you can do
for people is that for your relatives
when you die is number one to have your
affairs in order
alright and then number two is to not
have an entire house of [ __ ] that they
then have to go [ __ ] put into a
[ __ ] landfill somewhere or try to get
rid of it
Jesus Christ I made this [ __ ] old I
miss old now that I don't I have no
[ __ ] vices and I'm talking about
wrapping it up Jesus Christ bill you're
on the 12th hole okay you're trying to
break 80 here alright let's let's read
some of the let's read some of the the
[ __ ] advertising oh by the way have
you seen that this [ __ ] Bloomberg
might join the [ __ ] race here I got
to tell you for the first time in a long
time that actually made me excited about
politics just as far as the matchup a
billionaire versus a billionaire you
know they're claiming they're using
their own money which is [ __ ]
hilarious because I don't think you
became a billionaire by spending
hundreds of millions of dollars to go
going for a job that pays for five
hundred grand a year all right
unless unless the reason why these
lunatic billionaires Donald Trump and
[ __ ] Michael Bloomberg who said his
first thing
Bloomberg those two [ __ ] guys I think
that will they want that job because of
all of their other businesses and the
[ __ ] red tape that they can get rid
of for their businesses businesses that
they can get rid of by being in that
five hundred grand a year [ __ ] job
that's my only other theory cuz other
than that why would you want that job
we have never-ending Wars we're
consistently dropping bombs that [ __ ]
innocent people end up dying you have to
make the decision do we go in here do we
go in there is that a group of
terrorists and then it turns out to be a
wedding or whatever the [ __ ] happened
over there and you got to [ __ ] live
with that then you're gonna age in
[ __ ] dog ears and you're gonna make
500 grand a year and you're a [ __ ]
billionaire let me ask you this okay
let's all let's all play armchair
[ __ ] detectives here what is the
motivation alright don't even tell me
that you [ __ ] patriotic because the
way billionaires run their business has
nothing to do with America it has to do
all with the [ __ ] money and then
blaming the shareholders well you know
we do is what the shareholder is [ __ ]
wrong wailing woman all right
oh is this a thought I had before the
Super Bowl really quickly then I was
saying to all my buddies I was like you
know what this [ __ ] game is the
Chiefs versus the [ __ ] 49ers this is
the New England Patriots versus the New
York Jets ten years ago when Tom Brady a
[ __ ] world beater would come in with
an unbelievable offense in a decent
defense right and then he would go up
against Mark Sanchez a game manager with
the [ __ ] great defense now I think
Garoppolo is better than Sanchez
that's kind of what it was so I was just
you know when I did that thing on
Instagram when I posted I was making fun
of the Sports Talk and myself but like I
really did believe that and if the 49ers
were gonna win that they had to they had
to be playing with the lead because you
didn't want Garoppolo to have to be
playing [ __ ] ketchup although he made
some [ __ ] sick ass throws it really
was they started blitzing him in the
49ers did not adjust and then that was
it that was it and then I don't know
what the [ __ ] what happened with Tyree
quell he wasn't doing [ __ ] anything
the whole game and then all of a sudden
you know that guy bit on the inside move
and then [ __ ] mahomes threw a pass
that looked like a [ __ ] punt
I mean Tyree kill was underneath that I
was waiting for him to start waving his
arm for a fair catch and then all of a
sudden they just couldn't stop him ah
unbelievable unbelievable
I got to stop putting money on the game
why do you you you know what it is about
all of this whole [ __ ] Superbowl
thing was I predicted the 49ers were
gonna win and I was so loving it like on
I I see things I know what happens and
then I watched it all go away in ten
minutes
this is just all my [ __ ] ego let's
just shut the [ __ ] up and congratulate
the Kansas City Chiefs the old AFL
Chiefs plus I have a lot of [ __ ]
friends then a huge [ __ ] Kansas City
Chiefs fans one of the best [ __ ] guys
I've met in this business
alright the voice of Bob Poe go on f is
for family David Koechner easy I gotta I
gotta give him a [ __ ] call
congratulate him put my prediction and
my $200 aside and be a goddamn man about
it you know that's what this whole
[ __ ] thing is about it's not about
the holding that they let go it's about
the fact that I wanted to be right
that I wanted to have happen so I can
act like I knew things that others
didn't all right
see that right there that is age that is
that is wisdom
it took me [ __ ] a half an hour and I
apologized to chief fans that you had to
suffer through all of that um that's
what it was I said the 49ers were gonna
win and I bet $200 on it and I predicted
how the game was gonna go and it went
that way for 50 minutes and I thought I
was going to get all these a colloidal
aids a colloid hemorrhoids I don't know
how to say it and I thought I was going
to get all of that [ __ ] and in the end
the Chiefs talking away from me
it wasn't about Andy Reid that wasn't
about that that the city of Kansas City
Missouri or maybe it isn't Kansas it's
actually in both but that's not where
the chief play they play in Missouri
maybe it wasn't about that maybe it was
just about me hey how about this how
about what what were the [ __ ] odds in
Vegas I bet he could bet on this that in
five years the Kansas City Royals would
win a World Series in the Kansas City
Chiefs we're gonna win a [ __ ] Super
Bowl they got to get that out there
let's let's find another [ __ ]
sad-sack [ __ ] sports town all right
what are the odds let's pick a good one
here man there's a lot of cities where
there's this one sad-sack team but you
can't if the Pittsburgh pirate in the
who I mean the Steelers are whether the
one you know tied for the most Super
Bowl wins of all time the [ __ ] picks
for Pittsburgh Penguins have won four
Stanley Cups in the last [ __ ] 30
years can't can't can't jump on them
that doesn't work what's a [ __ ] sad
sack [ __ ] town I would have said
Houston but then they went ahead and
want it I think that that's what they
should do with the [ __ ] Houston
Astros instead of an ass trick you play
like Morse code after the
after their [ __ ] World Series today I
felt bad for [ __ ] Astros fans going
nuts thinking that you want it and then
it comes along that that [ __ ]
happened
unbelievable but I will say this is a
Patriots fan at least you [ __ ] did it
you know so you don't have to [ __ ]
worry about it
as opposed to being accused of something
that goes to a court of law that gets
laughed out of the [ __ ] courtroom the
judge actually gets mad and says why are
you wasting my your time my time with
this [ __ ] horseshit and then you
still get suspended for it alright sorry
although the Red Sox will you know I
wouldn't argue on any of them any of the
last four you know unless you're just
gonna say everybody was doing steroids I
wouldn't argue with you on any of those
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] all right zip
recruiter everybody zip hiring is a
challenge is challenging those hang in
there Millennials but there's one place
you can go where hiring I love blaming
Millennials to the point that they now
say okay boomer I just love it because
you know what I'm a gen Xer
and I just [ __ ] I just sit there just
getting both sides [ __ ] yelling at
each other but there's one place you can
go where hiring is simple fast and smart
and growing businesses visit this is
connect connect to qualified can't and a
growing businesses is connect to
qualified candidates Cafe alturas CEO my
favorite name of all time Dylan Miska
wits I love that if somebody tells you
that first names Dylan there's no
[ __ ] way you think that last name is
misko it's Dylan that's like a cowboy
name one of them one of them people out
there making it great
got themselves a ranch is my son Dylan
that's a stepbrother Dakota experienced
how challenging hiring can be after
unsuccessfully searching for a director
of coffee for his organic coffee company
but then he switched to zip that was
falling to your death saying that that
company's name and saw an immediate
difference and you two can't and you too
by signing up for free at sip recruiter
dot-com slash bird zip recruiter doesn't
spend doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you and
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates faster in fact after posting
his job on zip the good Dylan what do
they call what do they call their foot
what is a redneck call his house Dylan
said he was amazed by how quickly great
candidates were applied and found his
new director of coffee in just a few
days with results like that now one of
this guy's successful a guy named wasn't
Dylan Miska wits the amount of humanity
that he's covering right there huh
people in New York City all the way out
there they like coffee with results like
that it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first
days it the smartest way to hire CY zip
recruiters affected for businesses of
all sizes try zip recruiting for free at
our website
zip recruited comm / / that zip
recruited comm /b you are
or okay I love this company brave all
right brave everybody you know when I
think brave I don't think of a soldier
or a firefighter I think of a white a
young white woman who has called herself
this over doing nothing particularly
brave all right
brave everybody brave is the web browser
reimagined keep your personal
information private as you surf the web
you're living in their surveillance
economy what is that you might ask every
time you download a webpage you are not
just downloading the content text and
images you are also downloading privacy
invading trackers many popular media
sites have over 100 trackers on every
page
you're being profiled and tracked across
the web so you might say I mean that is
a Zen way to look at it your digital
profile includes information about you
such as your search and watch history
your personal beliefs or even your
location everywhere you've been
and even your current GPS coordinates I
don't get with all the [ __ ] women out
there with legit stalkers how that this
information is like like readily
available for someone to hack into and
find out where somebody is it's just
[ __ ] beyond me
thank God just somebody trying to do
something about these digital profiles
allow companies you have never heard of
to maintain intimate profiles about you
and everyone you know
brave stops data grabbing trackers and
creepy ads from following you across the
web which allows you to browse up to six
times faster than with other browsers
here's an important fact about us brave
isn't anti ads brave is anti tracking
brave users can choose to opt in to
brave ads a privacy respecting ad
network run by brave brave never sees
your personal data or behavior let alone
sells that information for profit
you'll never see an ad from brave unless
you explicitly choose to participate
participate the with brave ads you can
earn rewards for any ad you choose to
view that's right out-of-the-box brave
will block ads and trackers but you can
choose whether you want to see the ads
how often they appear and get rewarded
for your attention if you click on one
wait a minute
you get rewarded for attention if you
click on one okay so this is basically a
VIP relationship with you and ad
companies now I thought you were in
business to stop these guys you're now
in bed with them I don't get what's
going on here how does brave make money
all right there we go if you choose to
opt in to brave ads brave takes a cut of
the advertising spend whenever you
choose to view an ad that's how brave
earns money and keeps the browser free
all right well there you go it's better
than what you got right now I guess it
takes less than 60 seconds to switch to
brave important import your bookmarks
with one click and start enjoying a
better internet listeners of the mmm
podcast can easily switch to brave today
or go to brave comm slash burn and
download brave today that's brave calm
slash burn and switch today today today
all right Paul is the genius right
policy genius everybody you know the
year 2020 shows up a lot in science
fiction a lot of people predicted that
by now we'd be teleporting to work or
living on Mars some people predicted
that the 49ers we're gonna win and a lot
of those predictions were wrong the
truth is we will always get the future
wrong which is why we need to get life
insurance right
that's where policy genius can help
policy genius makes finding the right
life insurance a breeze in minutes you
can compare quotes from the top insurers
to find that your best price you could
save fifteen hundred dollars in lua a
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policy policies once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the
paperwork and red tape and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home in auto insurance or disability
insurance if your science-fiction dreams
for 2020 still haven't become science
fact don't get discouraged get life
insurance it takes get life insurance it
takes just a few minutes to find your
best price and apply at policy
genius.com
policy genius will always get the future
wrong but get life insurance right all
right but I'm gonna die in the future
I'm such a [ __ ] don't listen to me all
right let's get to some of the some of
the yeah somebody yeah the questions
here for the well this is the one that I
wanted to avoid because I've been having
a great time for breakfast I've been
sauteing spinach with garlic and I will
tell you this eating way more vegetables
and way less meat I afterwards I
definitely feel a lot lighter I just
what I just don't understand is why the
United States government does not get
involved well I know why cuz they're all
grossly underpaid and they get paid off
by these [ __ ] in the food industry why
is it so [ __ ] hard and they're all in
bed I think they're all in [ __ ] bed
with people who put out medicines and
they want you this to [ __ ] they want
they don't want you to be dead because
they can they stop making money off you
they want it they want you to be sick
and need their medicine to stay alive
and I think that there's a 200 thing
going on with the food industry and the
[ __ ] pharmaceutical companies I just
don't know it cuz explain to me with all
of this [ __ ] technology why it is so
[ __ ] difficult to find out whether an
egg is good for me or bad for me alright
game-changers doc now for those of you
who missed the last couple of episodes I
watched this [ __ ] documentary on
Netflix
all right then it was showing all these
amazing things about that if you just
stopped eating meat and all of this
stuff and you know the usual horseshit
you know we don't have [ __ ] carnivore
teeth and this guy ate [ __ ] spinach
all week look at his [ __ ] cholesterol
and look at this and it always goes out
to the [ __ ] you know the non meat
eaters right so hey here's somebody
gonna say so dear Billy radish face I
bet you're getting lots of love or hate
about being interested in a more of a
plant-based diet I am I don't know what
to believe the impossible burger I am
NOT eating that anymore I'm [ __ ] I'm
not [ __ ] with that thing I am a
guinea pig I'm gonna let other people be
a guinea pig and they're gonna start
getting if they start lactating that I
know I made the right decision if I die
and they don't then I know that they
were right anyway I was urged to watch
that documentary too and after all these
years I think I'm settling on the fact
that eggs are in fact healthy once they
said eating an egg once they said eating
an egg is like smoking a cigarette
I knew something was fishy ah look at
you with you a little pun there I felt
more like a Catholic priest painting an
image of Hell to scare parishioners than
a doctor with facts a few months later I
saw the guy behind the documentary James
Wilk and a gentleman by the name of
Chris crest neuron Joe Rogan's podcast
and this is why Joe Rogan's podcast is
the best [ __ ] podcast in the world if
you just want unfiltered information for
you to then digest and process and make
up your own [ __ ] mind yourself
because everything else is so [ __ ]
perverted and skewed I'm gonna watch
this episode Cressler was at one point
of vegan but now follows a diet based on
more up-to-date research that has
nuances as opposed to dogmatic views the
debate is excellent wilkes does a great
job defending some of his points but in
the end fails to show any proof that
Egan's are healthier I appreciate
Cressler and Rogen's breaking down the
differences between someone who eats
quality meats and vegetables and someone
who eats any meats and fried foods ie
your body digests meats differently if
it's being combined with a plate of
french fries as opposed to spinach yeah
I've always heard that like a starch
with meat is is bad red meat
particularly but most research in the
past did you read a pill or did somebody
say that to you and you took it for law
because you don't want to read up on it
my problem is when you try to try to get
the information and like trying to get
to the truth it's because there's so
many just [ __ ] lies and people just
[ __ ] just trying to sell you on
whatever the [ __ ] there's their scent
like food is literally it's like it's
like pop music and every year there's a
new boy band that they're shoving down
your [ __ ] throat you know kale right
kale for a couple years
oh right there right there all the girls
were screaming and now the new one who
knocked them off the charts the
impossible burger right all of a sudden
they're out there the big pouty [ __ ]
lips and they're leather jackets so you
know that they're tough to write anyway
I appreciate Cressida Rogan breaking
down the difference Baba ie your body
digests meat differently if it's
combined with the plate of french fries
as opposed to spinach but most research
in the past 40 some-odd years does not
take these things into consideration
next it's like politics they do the same
thing they leave out [ __ ] next time
you're taking a bath and it needs some
some small talk with a friend call Joe
for more details on this or just watch
it yourself now I'm not gonna bug
I'll watch it and then you know he'll
get another hit you know Mickey he'll
make some more [ __ ] money that's what
you do
you know burden a friend he was nice
enough to interview these [ __ ] people
and post a video on it instead I'm gonna
call him up and make him relive what he
already did why the [ __ ] would I do that
because bubble baths can get lonely
maybe that's why all right
DNC did not communicate when is that
Democratic National Committee I always
took that as a democratic party
Democratic National Convention that's
what it is hey Bill you saw that the DNC
is changing its rules to make it so
Bloomberg can get into the debates
months after changing them to make it
impossible for Tulsi or yang to get in
honey I don't I really I'm kind of glad
I don't know what any of this means
because if I knew what this means then I
would just be frustrated and angry like
you as opposed to just ignorant over
here trying to figure out if Brussels
sprouts is the way for me to live in
extra six months or not how do you have
to be how dumb do you have to be to not
realize the fixes in they keep moving
the goal posts I have friends who are
still following this impeachment
[ __ ] I know I just don't understand
people wasting their time with that like
he's actually gonna get impeached can
you bet on that in Vegas how much money
do I have to make to earn a dollar that
he isn't a billion to make a dollar
while the Democrats smother Bernie with
[ __ ] talk Hillary trashes him for no
reason
I know hell hath no fury like a [ __ ]
woman who thought she was going to be
presidents scorned like Hillary trashes
him for no reason like a shitty aunt who
stirs up problems in the family for no
reason the establishment would rather
Trump stay in even if they hate him god
forbid the country vote in two
back-to-back presidents that weren't
handpicked by the heads of the
established party
if you bring up all this [ __ ] with
anyone who calls themselves a Democrat
they start telling you that you're
stumping for Trump is there a proper way
to explain to someone there being had
hey I think I represent a lot of voters
out there in that I only vote when it's
for the president which is really a
horrible thing to do
I just find it also overwhelmingly
depressing you know I used to hang in
there and I would always vote for the
Bernie Sanders and the who is that guy
there that [ __ ] everybody blamed for
[ __ ] Bush getting in rather than the
fact that Al Gore was completely outside
his own body the entire time he was
running I don't know I would always vote
for those guys and Ross Perot's and
these guys who were actually saying what
the [ __ ] was going on and that was
corrupt and all that and people always
say it's a waste of a vote it's like you
got a vote for the corrupt guy of your
party that's playing the game I would
love to hear the argument for that and I
would also love to hear the argument for
no-holds-barred capitalism in the
direction that it's led us in and how
everybody's up so many people are upside
down in their houses and I don't know
who they're building all these luxury
high-rise apartments for I don't
understand who has these [ __ ] money
and then how you then sell them to
people in from China in Russia who are
trying to wash their money like I don't
understand their money I don't
understand any of it that's why I just
sort of tapped out and I'm trying to
just sort of be a you know on a local
level trying to just shop at local
businesses you know going to Skid Row
and dropping off [ __ ] rather than taking
it to [ __ ] goodwill I mean I don't
know what else to do if anybody has a
suggestion
I'm up for it not saying I'm gonna do it
but I could read it on the podcast and
then communicate it to people in money
to try and raise money for public
schools in your area so people still
have a chance the same chance my parents
had when they had a bunch of kids to
send them to school for free
well tax dollars grades 1 through 12 I
don't know all right advice cash job
problems hey Billy bad ass actor copper
copper I get it nice I'm a carpenter
from Newfoundland and worked 50 plus
hours a week for cash on the weekends 50
plus hours a week for a cash on the
weekends occasionally with one of my old
employers what happened to the last half
of that sentence I'll never know I've
been working for cash with this company
for about two years now and haven't had
an issue with payment up to this point
work is slow right now and he informed
me the other day that he could not pay
me the money he owes me $700 he said he
could pay me in gas cards or he could
buy tools from Home Depot and pay me
that those because he can include that
in the company expense the problem with
this is that my girlfriend of four years
is now pissed off that I'm not getting
paid I couldn't care less as long as I
get something for my work and I love to
tools so should I stand up to my old
employer and tell him he has to pay me
in cash or should I tell my girlfriend
to back off and mind her own business
thanks for thanks love the podcast and
as always go [ __ ] yourself now PS you
should really consider coming to
Newfoundland to do work show I think I
did it a number of years ago I mean I
went to Halifax Gaffigan was scheduled
to come down here but we had a record
snowfall and he couldn't make it
ninety-five centimeters in one day not
bad haha I don't even know how much that
is let's let's look that up so I can
actually answer this question even
though this has nothing to do with it I
now intrigued 95 centimeters to inches
at 37 inches you had three feet one inch
plus of snow all right well let me ask
you this dude how the [ __ ] are you gonna
pay your rent if you don't have legal
tender it's not like the old days where
you can just trade come into town with
some eggs and a yak and trade that for
your [ __ ] to your landlord you must have
enough cash to pay your rent if you have
enough cash to pay your rent I kind of
like a man that's still around to tell
them that it will actually tell the
woman in his life to back off and mind
her own business although if she lives
with you it is kind of her business so I
don't know where to go and then I'm just
it's just great to hear a guy standing
up to a woman at some point by the way I
just want to commend all the feminist
groups that [ __ ] were [ __ ] all
over Johnny Depp for now admitting that
you maybe jump the gun and just
supported somebody with little to no
evidence just because like you they also
had a vagina I want to thank all of you
guys for then writing your wrongs and
being big enough people to to admit that
you were wrong now I've done it on this
podcast will I realize that my petty
[ __ ] about the officiating in the Super
Bowl really came down to me and my ego
and wanting to be right about my
prediction now when you're a feminist
your Super Bowl is arguments between men
and women and you know what you got this
one wrong it looks like you know where's
all the retraction ladies that'll never
happen
all right screen time dear Billy
Guardian I agree with your stance with
you stance on screen time for kids I'm
not naive enough to think that having
some idea how to work technology is good
for a kid just like video games weren't
as bad as parents in the 80s thought
they'd be I I don't know what the [ __ ] I
just read I'm gonna read this word for
it I agree with you stance on screen
time for kids I'm not naive enough to
think that having some idea how to work
technology is
for a kid just like video games weren't
as bad as parents in the 80s thought
they'd be alright this is what happens
when you have too much screen time this
is how you put together sentences the
problem ahem of having is with my wife
she doesn't seem interested in playing
with our child one on one as much as I
do and it's disheartening
she's always turning to Netflix to
babysit while she sits there on her
phone yeah you're dealing with the
[ __ ] screen addict I think that
that's a new thing that they haven't
diagnosed yet our marriage is a bit
strained for this and other reasons I'm
fairly convinced she's cheating on me
I've turned but I'm compartmentalizing
this from the parenting from parenting
to try and be fair if we get divorced I
won't be there to see what's going on
and that bothers me in the meantime I
wish there was some way to make her
understand that the stimulant
stimulation our kid gets from staring at
screens while sitting five feet in front
of her mother on the floor is not the
same as sitting across from a child and
talking and teaching any advice on how
to get the message across
yeah there's studies out there that yet
you know on the internet that somebody
gave me I would just google that and
then show the adverse effects of it
especially with the developing mind I am
I'm huge huge huge on like we barely let
our kid watch TV no we never really let
it get too out of hand and the more I
read about it we just sort of stopped
doing it and she had her favorite shows
that she watches and she you know she
whined about it for like a week and a
half and you know they're so young they
forget about it and now we you know she
draws she colors you know she takes
French classes she actually understands
French when the lady talks to her it's
[ __ ] amazing we do puzzles we ride
bikes you know she knows how she's
learned almost
knows how to swim now I think all of
that stuff you know as much as you're
worried that they're going to get behind
and computers of the future and all of
that [ __ ] with the skills that they're
learning not being involved in this
stuff that they're gonna be fine
and there has to be you know people who
are aware of this stuff and they also
know that computers is here to stay that
also has to be some sort of quality ways
to have screen time that involves
teaching and not like because I was just
noticing like when my kid would be
watching TV and I'd be calling her and
calling her and calling her and calling
have to say it like five times they just
get like [ __ ] zoned out it's not good
and I watched a ton of TV and I think I
have you know some sort of side effect
from that I'm a bit lack of ability to
focus or whatever I don't know I feel
bad for you dude you're in a real tough
position because if you're a woman you
could go to court and present all of
that and you would you would win custody
but they do not treat guys fairly in
those cases whatsoever so I would yeah
that's not that's a [ __ ] tough one
man it's time to open that dialogue that
when you're in a relationship with a
woman and the woman is doing [ __ ] that's
detrimental to your kid like there has
to be avenues for a man to [ __ ] turn
to and there just really isn't and the
blind support that women have for other
women for the most part straight across
the board is really detrimental to the
kid you know that that whole
and philosophy that believe women is is
like so horrendously flawed because if
to say that you're just saying that then
that men are flawed and women aren't if
you're just straight across the board
gonna do that and then in bully and
intimidate people by threatening to take
away their careers unless they agree
with you it's just [ __ ] it's just not
a good thing it's not an adult thing
it's not a mature way to go about
solving a [ __ ] problem
and I feel like emotions have come down
enough where you know you can actually
maybe start talking about that [ __ ] but
I feel really bad for you dude because
I've had disagreements with my wife
about that stuff and people are flawed
as am i and like we we had this amazing
breakthrough with my anger now like my
kid is like my [ __ ] life coach now
she literally said said be like Dada
Dada da Dada da duh don't yell it's
gonna be okay she literally says it to
me and I crack up laughing and I go
you're right it is I'm sorry and then
she laughs and I've made this major
breakthrough in my family tree of
dysfunction where now my anger that I
learned or whatever is open for
discussion and we can laugh about it my
kid is not even remotely afraid of me or
anything all the [ __ ] that I had growing
up you know with the adults in my life
has completely imploded and it's all on
the table now I still have the anger
issues that I have to work through but
like the fact that right as I get going
she says you know dad don't yell don't
yell and I just I just stopped now you
know I just you know I can't
there's no I there's just no way I can't
continue when I hear that voice say that
so it's this weird thing where I still
am now instead of snapping I start to
snap and if I really feel that I have to
get it out of me
I just leave the house and I just go out
into the garage and I just go play drums
or something I almost need to have like
the Frank Murphy heavy bag to hit it
sometimes but you know it's been this
amazing you know of all the the gifts
that becoming a dad has been for me the
fact that she's actually helping the
part of myself that I hate the most has
just been this this ridiculous cherry on
top so anyway now you know where the
[ __ ] I'm going with those
all right sober activity all right
captain Billy how about making one of
those ships in a bottle have I ever
taken the time to thank you guys for
making me laugh too because you really
do all right I know I tried to do it
with you but the fact that I get it back
is [ __ ] great all right imagine you
with a monocle on carefully lining up
the mast sails or whatever you call them
wife calls you from the house dinner is
ready
you rest your tools eagerly awaiting the
next time you're one-on-one with
tranquility really relaxing right yeah
what is with that [ __ ] don't you [ __ ]
I feel like the you just put the bottle
together right you know after you build
the [ __ ] ship but what do you have to
do you got to have like tweezers and all
of that type of thing it really is like
you know the Super Bowl of patience if
they actually take little pieces but
doesn't make any sense how would you get
the mast in there without it being
creased I think it's like the bottom of
the bottle [ __ ] twists off I don't
know
you know it's hilarious is that back in
the day that probably got a guy laid oh
my god he
we'll be if such a patient partner all
right that's the podcast congratulations
to the Kansas City Chiefs sorry about
the [ __ ] wine and about the
officiating a little bit there that
really came down to the fact that I had
money on the [ __ ] 49ers and I wanted
to be right that's all it was because in
reality as a Patriots fan I should be
excited that they didn't join us in the
family of six oh and then it would have
been six six six and all the Jesus
freaks would have come out and said that
the NFL is [ __ ] evil you know because
it's six six six rather than the fact
that they look the other way and all the
[ __ ] brain damage their employees
have gotten over the years it's not that
it's the number six all right that's it
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves I
have fun there in Kansas City eat all
the barbecue you want goddamn it you
guys deserve that I was just a hell of a
game and an undeniable championship by
the Kansas City Chiefs they went down
and every [ __ ] playoff game they
played and they just came roaring back
so enjoy the hockey enjoy the [ __ ]
hoop enjoy the college basketball and
all the other [ __ ] as we wait for
baseball season to start everybody I'll
check in on you on Thursday